Cher Adam et Cheney, l'une des choses
que j'aime le plus au monde est À
bas les mythes, ce serait mon rêve devenu
réalité
si je pouvais vous aider les gars à casser un
homme de Star Wars, j'adore Sophia, qu'est-ce que c'était que
notre transition maladroite pour présenter
notre actrice Sophia  Bush
q star du [ __ ] de Chicago de NBC et grande
fan de Mythbusters Sophia Bush bonjour
messieurs
Jamie puis-je être votre princesse Leia Oh
merde
maintenant Jamie vous voulez souligner que
Sophia est venue jouer habillée le rôle et
tout ce que vous ne pensez pas
vouloir  pour mettre quelque chose d'un peu plus
approprié bien
tu as l'air fantastique Jamie s'est glissé
dans quelque chose d'un peu plus
inconfortable tu as l'air fantastique
pour savoir si le swing de Star Wars est
possible avec la ceinture de rupture de
côtes en faveur d'un harnais de sécurité d'abord
peut-il accrocher  sur Sophia en
traversant le gouffre pour vérifier le gréement
Jamie vole d'abord en solo trois deux un
puis se prépare pour la vraie
affaire
bien faite bravo avec un diable factice
donc si y  ous c'est comme ça que ça va
être quand tu seras ici avec moi alors
on y va tu pourras tenir
bon bon travail Jimmy
je suis convaincu que Jamie ne va pas
me laisser tomber alors je suis juste excité  monter
là-haut et le faire c'est exactement la
bonne attitude je pense que tu vas
beaucoup t'amuser ouais les deux bras ne sont pas comme
mon père donc ça revient à ça comment
tu tiens la corde je la tiens  avec
cette main, les deux premières pièces
du puzzle ont déjà prouvé leur plausibilité,
Jaime est habilement attaché pour le
troisième et dernier test, les
soldats de la tempête à deux
orteils sont prêts, c'est à vous d'
entrer dans le personnage
.  en venant, nous devons sortir d'ici,
vous l'avez totalement fait
l'Empire après toute cette panne
et toute cette planification qui n'aurait pas
pu aller mieux
très satisfaisant à chaque instant autant de plaisir que
vous pensez
bien nous avons à peu près réussi cela mais je
dois dire  la plupart des choses que nous
testons ici ont été assez bord  erline
entend une autre personne dans une situation de vie ou de
mort, bien sûr, mais tout est plutôt louche,
vraiment
bien, les mecs, nous n'avons pas beaucoup de temps
parce que l'Empire arrive, comment
voulez-vous appeler celle-ci Sophia, nous l'avons fait,
je dis plausible Jamie, eh bien toi
sais que c'est clairement possible mais
ça me donne envie de dire que c'est confirmé
Oh
combats-moi et mets